CON ON THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER AND BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA, LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. LAYERED LAYERED HERE.
ASHBY ASHBY HERE, CORTEZ CORTEZ
HERE, GONZALEZ GROVE GROVE HERE.
JONES JONES. HERE LEE HERE.
MAGUIRE NEWMAN. NEWMAN HERE.
NILO NILO HERE, RUBIO RUBIO
PRESENT SMALL CUEVAS. ALL WOULD
QUOTE. CREVIS HERE. WIENER WILK
QUORUM. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
QUORUM BEFORE WE BEGIN THE
AGENDA. LET ME QUICKLY TALK
ABOUT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
MEETING AT THE BEGINNING OF EACH
LEGISLATIVE SESSION FOR PURSUANT
TO JOINT RULE 40, THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE MUST ESTABLISH
THE CHAIR, THE VICE CHAIR AND
THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
. THE COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY
APPROVED MYSELF AS VICE CHAIR
AND CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
LEO LOPEZ AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS TWO YEAR SESSION. THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY'S MEETING IS TO
APPROVE SPEAK. REVIS' NEW CHAIR
OF THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE,
THE MEMBERS OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE OF EACH HOUSE MAY BE
MAY MEET SEPARATELY. SO WE ARE,
UM AND CONSIDER ANY ACTION THAT
IS REQUIRED TO BE TAKEN BY THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE IF THE
MAJORITY OF MEMBERS OF EACH
HOUSE AT THE SEPARATE MEETINGS
VOTE IN FAVOR OF AN ACTION, THE
ACTION SHALL BE CONSIDERED
APPROVED BY THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE. SO WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY WE'RE
MEETING HERE TODAY, IN LINE WITH
THE RULES WE HAVE THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSED CONS. ITEM ITEM ONE.
THE SELECTION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA PACHECO AS CHAIR OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON RULES. DO I
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS ITEM? I
THINK THIS IS GOING TO PASS BY
THE NUMBER OF MOTIONS, BUT I
WILL TAKE SENATOR ASHBY'S MOTION
WITH THE SECRETARY OF POLICE.
CALDERON LAD, LAD. I ASHBY.
ASHLEY I CORTEZ CORTEZ, I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ, I GROVE GROVE
. I JONES JONES. I LEMON LEMON.
I MCGUIRE NEWMAN NEWMAN. I NELO
NELO I RUBIO RUBIO. I SMALL
CUEVAS SMALL VÀ I WIENER WIENER.
I WILK. 12. TO ZERO. FOR SERVICE
ON CONDITION 12 TO 0. OK THAT IS
12 TO 0. WE'RE GONNA, UH, TAKE
THAT AS A PASS AND CLOSE THE
ROLL. THE SENATE CONTINGENT ON
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE HEARING.
LET'S LET EVERYBODY HAVE A
CHANCE TO MOVE OUT. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR DILIGENCE IN BEING
HERE.